bom é olá a todos
é normalmente quando eu falo sobre esse
tema as mudanças climáticas
eu gosto de desmistificar um pouco sobre
isso porque normalmente é a gente escuta
muito falar sobre as mudanças climáticas
né
e aí tudo o que a gente vê no tempo de
uma forma geral não se choveu muito
mudanças climáticas se não choveu nada
mudança no clima se junho que
normalmente é uma época mais fria né a
gente tem aí um dia com 13 graus 12° a
mudança do clima ou se janeiro que
normalmente é uma época também muito
mais chuvosa e mais quente a gente tem
um dia que chove muito e que chega a 35
graus mudança do clima e na verdade não
é bem assim que funciona coisa quando a
gente está falando em clima
a gente está falando de uma média
histórica de 30 anos de dados
atmosféricos
então a gente mede por 30 anos
diariamente quanto choveu quantos graus
fez qualquer o tempo ea gente faz uma
média estatística simples e aí a gente
consegue falar sobre o clima de uma
região sobre o clima de um local
e aí quando a gente está falando de
média média é aquela velha a história se
eu jantei dois frangos e você não jantou
nenhum frango na média eu já tenho um
frango e você um frango
só que existe uma variabilidade nessa
nesses frango sair né porque eu tô com
dois e você está com 10
então quando a gente está falando de
clima é muito normal ter essa
variabilidade climática principalmente
quando a gente fala de chuva
então por exemplo aqui no gráfico da à
direita eu tenho os dados é de todos os
postos meteorológicos do estado de são
paulo que registraram chuva de 1960 até
então todos os postos fizeram essas
linhas aí de várias cores né no eixo
x eu tenho um ano e no eixo y eu tenho
quanto de chuva que foi registrada no 2º
gráfico a gente fez uma média de todos
os postos que aquela linha preta
a média de todos aqueles postos juntos
deu aquela linha vermelha que é em torno
de mil e 400 milímetros por ano
então na média todo o estado de são
paulo chove 1.400 milímetros por ano
só que reparem que é muito difícil a
gente tem um ano que choveu exatamente
1.400 milímetros
é muito normal ter essa variabilidade
então tem ano é que ultrapassa os dois
mil e tem anos que que está abaixo de
mel é muito normal então tem essa
variabilidade
então não é porque choveu muito humano
ou choveu pouco em outro ano que a gente
está falando de mudança do clima
a gente só consegue falar em mudança do
clima depois que a gente tiver muitos
anos de dado e conseguiu modificar por
exemplo aquela linha vermelha
aí sim a gente pode estar falando que o
clima está mudando
então quando vocês escutarem aquela
aquela velha frase né
choveu tanto os milímetros acima da
média ou choveu que era esperado para
chover no mês de janeiro desconfiem um
pouco dessa informação porque não é bem
assim que a banda toca pra gente falar
efetivamente de mudanças climáticas é
muito importante a gente entender uma
outra história que chama efeito estufa
o efeito estufa é um fenômeno natural
que ocorre na terra
e é justamente por causa dele que a
terra de uma maneira geral tem
aproximadamente 15 graus
se não fosse ele a terra seria em torno
de 30 graus mais fria do que ela é hoje
então imaginem que a terra está dentro
de uma estufa que essa figura aqui do
lado direito
os gases de efeito estufa que são gases
naturais seriam como se fosse o vidro da
estufa e aí então entre a radiação a
rádio
não chega até a gente parte dela volta
fica presa num vidro e outra parte
retorna
essa parte que fica presa então no vidro
faz com que a terra se esquente e tem
aproximadamente 15 graus que nem eu
falei no entanto nos últimos anos o que
a gente reparou né o que tem dito que
uma série de atividades humanas e dentre
essas atividades é dá para destacar a
indústria as áreas agrícolas dentre
outras
a gente tem tido um excesso desses gases
de efeito estufa
então o nosso vidrinho ali ele ficou
muito mais grosso de uma forma geral
então a radiação chega a parte dela
passa e aí então fica presa ali na terra
ea terra esquenta ea isso a gente dá o
nome de aquecimento global
com o aquecimento global a gente tem uma
modificação geral de diversas
circulações e aí sim a gente consegue
falar em mudanças climáticas é nos
cenários futuros de mudanças climáticas
o que tem visto é que a gente pode ter
uma série de eventos extremos dentre
eles a gente pode ter excesso de chuva
de uma forma geral
então aquela variabilidade ela vai ficar
muito mais intensa e muito mais
freqüente
então a gente pode ter muita chuva a
gente pode ter um excesso de secas muito
mais intensas e muito mais freqüentes
a gente também pode ter ondas de frio
então é se a gente acha que porque está
ficando mais quente a terra é a gente
não vai ter frio a gente se engana
porque a gente pode ter muito mais ondas
de frio de uma forma geral a gente
também pode ter dias muito quentes muito
mais quentes do que é o do que a gente
espera para aquela época ea população de
uma forma geral sofre todo mundo sofre
todos eles independente de raça de cor
de credo todo mundo pode sofrer no
entanto há os mais pobres de uma maneira
geral eles são mais vulneráveis eles
devem sofrer mais com esses eventos mais
extremos com essa freqüência maior e com
essa intensidade maior
as atividades humanas também devem
sofrer de uma forma bastante intensa e
dentre elas a agricultura é uma das que
mais pode sofrer
isso porque as plantas de uma maneira
geral têm uma faixa climática adequada
na qual elas crescem modificando então
essa faixa do clima as plantas devem
sofrer de uma forma bem intensa aqui
então a gente tem alguns exemplos como a
soja o feijão não é que podem perder
essa área que é climaticamente adaptada
ao plantio
a gente pode perder aí aproximadamente
7,6 bilhões de reais quando a gente está
falando de soja isso num cenário
climático futuro mais quente ou aí mais
de 400 milhões de reais quando a gente
está falando em feijão ou por exemplo é
mais de um bilhão de real quando a gente
está falando em milho e assim a gente
vai uma série de culturas devem sofrer
de uma forma bem intensa
quando a gente fala de mudanças do clima
de uma forma geral no entanto é não vai
ser o fim do mundo né as plantas
agrícolas elas conseguem se adaptar a um
cenário climático futuro mais quente e
também existem atividades agrícolas que
podem mitigar esse excesso de gases de
efeito estufa
então por exemplo se a gente reflorestar
áreas se a gente plantar de uma forma
mais é com árvores e plantas e criar boi
juntamente com árvores e por exemplo as
culturas arborizadas
elas podem ser adaptadas a esse cenário
climático futuro mais quente as plantas
de uma forma geral elas conseguem
seqüestra é parte desses gases de efeito
estufa e armazenar é tanto na planta
quanto no solo então embora as
atividades agrícolas sejam também
responsáveis por parte dessas emissões
desses gases
elas também podem seqüestrar grande
parte grande parte desses gases
é e para finalizar o que eu queria falar
é que na verdade a responsabilidade é
toda nossa
então se o ser humano de uma maneira
geral esse as atividades agrícolas
inclui nisso né
atividades mais sustentáveis atividades
que consigam seqüestrar a partir desses
gases e atividades é que possam ser
energeticamente mais limpas
a gente consegue adaptar as plantas
agrícolas a esse cenário climático mais
quente e também mitigar grande parte
desses gases de efeito estufa
então a responsabilidade é toda nossa
boa tarde